joining us from the worldwide leader in
sports where he has done terrific work
since stepping off the field in the
National Football League he spent eight
years with the Pittsburgh Steelers he is
Ryan Clark how are you Ryan
I'm doing better we haven't spoken in a
long long time you're doing a great job
you're doing a great job and I really
appreciate it
you bet so I just want to get right into
it because I know you're at the the
Under Armour game right where Mariucci
is trying not to screw things up on the
sidelines the control I believe he's
actually coaching my son
are you serious playing in the game so I
think I think Steve was his coach and
moochers doing a great job those guys
I'm not a big timer yet so I'm just
going to a great game okay one day I'll
move fantastic okay great
let's get into the here and now
obviously with Antonio Brown and Big Ben
and Mike Tomlin what in the world do you
think is happening there right now
because it's sure I think I think this
is something that has just grown over
time rich I think coach Tomlin does a
great job with letting players feed
individuals and letting players have
their wrong person Natalie and I think
some of that is some guys don't
understand how to handle it and you know
I told a story on SVP the other night
and for good bad or worse or whatever
people have felt how they felt about it
but it's a true story you know I'm
standing in the weight room as Antonio
Brown walks by on the day that he's
supposed to finish his deal you know and
I talked to one of the strength coaches
or the hand strength coach I say listen
we all give it this money you know y'all
create a hostage y'all gonna have to be
able to handle it I'm sure enough the
next practice we go out and it's the
tone on Keenan Lewis is playing and gets
a little too physical he starts to
scream franchise you can't put your
hands on me like that he gets into it
with coach big Love Boat was a
hall-of-famer someone that Troy and I
either would question or talk to in that
way and he and I almost come to blows
you know over that just because I just
didn't like the attitude I didn't like
the start of that and then we've seen
different things throughout his career
per get progress and come to light
publicly and some of those thing is
richer obviously they obviously pale in
comparison to many things that happen
behind
is that people don't know and I think
just in the locker room in general they
just had enough of it and for what I
hear from talking to different people
there that situation and his growing you
know a discontent with the team and with
certain things has really worn on his
team as years progressed well Mike
Talman speaking to the media as you and
I are talking right now Ryan and you
know the question is is is has he lost
control of this situation I mean you
could essentially make that case viably
right now what do you think you know
yeah well you know I think he hesitant
control in the way that he wants or the
way that he feels he needs to obviously
to me on the outside looking in I feel
you have lost control if it comes down
to costing you winning football games if
it comes down to the fabric of the
locker room and and where it needs to be
and obviously you look on the other side
of it rich and you better learn a little
much if you understand that good players
get certainly late and you know I would
venture to say that many of us believe
Antonio Brown is Waterdeep best players
in the NFL so I think it's allowed him a
little latitude in the way that he's
been dealt with but I think coach Tomlin
really has to look into this situation
now in the offseason and see if having
Antonio Brown on that team with this
production and with what with uh what he
can bring to the field if that outweighs
the problems that he is causing now in
the locker room and now also publicly
that these things are starting to seep
into Tonio Brown not even dressing out
for games and being in a mink coat
leaving you know reportedly it has Ryan
Clark from ESPN here on the Rich Eisen
show former Pittsburgh Steeler well the
thing that makes this a
three-dimensional game of crazy chess
Ryan is that Big Ben also has had a lot
of leeway given his way and for him to
go on his radio show this week and say
he doesn't know where this quote-unquote
comes from about an altercation at a
walkthrough that everybody who was there
and is said on the record or off the
record to reporters to me
to me he had the ball thrown at him so
how can I sit there and say what he said
and say I welcomed him with open arms
when you can't tell what's going on and
from who Ryan well so so here here is
what I'll say the way I see the
situation obviously we've seen been at
different times say things publicly
about players you know whether it be on
the field off the field away so it was
about levian away those ball Martavious
in different things where he's had to
bring to light some of the things we
didn't look didn't know if you look at
this situation rich he doesn't have to
write like you said you had people
whether it's on the record or off the
record saying these things happen right
saying this happened to Antonio Brown so
now here's an opportunity where Ben
doesn't have to be the bad guy right
then doesn't have to tell us what
happened because we're hearing it from
different places Ben doesn't have to say
that he wouldn't welcome Antonio wrong
with open arms because other people were
there because Tomlin Kevin Cobra the GM
or the Pittsburgh Steelers now they have
to deal with the situation so Ben gets
an opportunity to be neutral to be a
leader to protect the Antonio Brown in
some sort of way because everyone else
is telling the story and so for Ben to
come out and say what he said I'm not
sure why I'm sure he has a most behind
it I'm sure he has a reason and maybe
it's because the Tony was catching so
much like and he wants to take some of
that off of him but you know I think you
know you and I and many others believe
that this altercation did happen I
believe that something needs to be done
whether it's finding a way to comment on
finding a way to punish him or finding a
way to shop him and get something back
from him because you can't lose him the
same way you lost levy on bill if you
feel like he can't be a part of this
change well he's asked for a trade
according to Jason Lockett for ax and
you know the Steelers rarely accommodate
team players that do this sort of thing
we just saw what happened with levy on
bail and as I mentioned at the top of
our program the salary cap situation it
would cost him 21 million dollars to get
rid of him trade or cut and it's Moffet
so they're going to be trade and 22
million to have him
so it's it's it makes no sense to trade
him essentially unless he is such a
problem so what what is the what's the
out here I mean with Rooney Tomlin Big
Ben a B what's what's the solution here
do you think you know I don't like you
know when you look at the numbers
there's no feasible out right when you
look at the numbers and you look at
business which football is it makes more
sense to keep him on the team and I
think that that's what they're going to
try to do I like I said in talking to
people
football players know how to play right
if Antonio Brown comes to place Antonio
Brown behaves in a way in the locker
room and on the field that makes him at
least decent teammate I believe he's a
guy you want but can you make that
happen are there pieces you can put in
place if your coach Tomlin to ensure
that that's the way that this team rolls
because we all believe they have the
talent we all believe if they have the
pieces but when you see the season like
we've seen this year it's so much
infighting with different people coming
out in the media and exposing some
things that usually aren't exposed from
active players or teams it just seems
tough to eat that you find an in-house
solution while keeping him there but
that's going to be the challenge for my
talent that's gonna be the challenge for
Ben Roethlisberger's for a tornado
problem because this window for the
Pittsburgh Steelers is currently
constructed is closing now and do you
waste time trying to get rid of Antonio
Brown and rebuild do you keep him and
figure out a way to make this
relationship cynical it's the last one
for you Ryan who's lost the locker room
the most Antonio Brown Ben
Roethlisberger or or Tomlin because
there are some players that are not
happy with the way that Tomlin handled
last week's situation yeah you know I
would have to say it's coach Tomlin in
the sense that you know and obviously by
local time I believe in everything he
does I always have I followed everything
he said but I believed in this situation
players are waiting for him to do
something to fix the Antonio Brown
situation players are waiting for him to
step in and do something that not only
makes or hose Antonio accountable but
also allows him to play
help this team win games and when you
have a situation that you allow to get
to this point and then after allowing it
to get to this point you sit your best
player and that best player doesn't come
out and steal the gear it doesn't come
out to support the team has on a mink
coat and leave it shows his lack of
respect for your authority so something
has to be done something has to be six
and I believe it also has to be public
because this situation has become so
public sober coach Tomlin this is going
to be a very pivotal moment it was
already been his long head coaching
career Pittsburgh well enjoy the Under
Armour game hanging out there
broadcasting it with ESPN and then
watching your son what position does he
play
he played corner he plays corner and
he's gonna go he's going to ASU next
year or the place okay well congrats on
that Ryan and honey and don't let mooch
screw it up I mean he's already got it
all set I mean seriously of all economy
prime I mean prime could you know maybe
teach them ting anything to do about
locking it down at that position you
know Luke says the head coach's
experience ralina Noah excellent Ryan
thanks for the call great job as always
with ESPN and I'd love to have you back
on the show soon thank you so much for
have a Googler that's Ryan Clark of ESPN
and formerly the National Football
League year and the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience